Apple just announced the new iPad Pro, and
to be honest following the rumors beforehand
this was the device I was least excited about.
During the announcement though, as soon as
they revealed it and especially when they
talked about specs my jaw kept dropping more
and more.
After the event was over, the new iPad Pro’s
are what I’m most excited about, and yes
we are getting one in so make sure you click
that subscribed button to see some great content
on it, and while you’re down there don’t
forget to hit that bell icon.
Now even though its the biggest update to
the iPad ever, and that A12X bionic processor
is ridiculously powerful, beating out even
the most expensive 15” 2017 Macbook Pro,
its not all rainbows and sunshine.
Here are 5 top problems with the iPad Pro.
is going to be the price.
The 11 inch costs $150 more then before, and
the 12.9” $200 more.
Apple charging more per device, and those
that just bought it will have a tough time
upgrading.
In fact just yeterday they annoucned they
won’t reveal sales figures.
You have to buy the new Apple Pencil.
$129.
New one is great, this is how it
should be from the start.
RAM.
Only in the $1550 11inch and $1750 12.9”
Device that will replace your PC, with super
powerful apps like Photoshop and Lightroom.
Video editing etc.
OnePlus 6 has 8GB.
No headphone jack.
What about DJ’s that they showed off.
There is enough space, this is a pro device.
When will they take it out of the Macbooks.
Now we’re not certain yet, but most likely
they won’t include an adapter either.
Keyboard.
Not only does it cost more, but you can no
longer fold it back to have a slim standing
profile which is really useful when you have
limited space.
The new keyboard case which covers the back
does allow for two viewing angles, but the
keyboard sticks out more now than it did before
taking up a lot more room so those of you
who loved this layout that was possible with
both the smart and smart keyboard, its no
longer available.
Thankfully if you don’t need the keyboard,
you
can buy the smart folio for way less and
you can have that setup, and it also covers
the front and back, and gets rid of the camera
bump, but unfortunately, it's now only available
in soft plastic instead of premium leather
with a $10 higher price.
Camera.
Smart HDR, Nice Quality, But no OIS.
Really helpful for lowlight and videos, doing
AR.
If we’re already going to have a substatial
camera bump that won’t allow this otherwise
boxy device to lay perfectly flat on the table,
why not make it just slighlyl larger and add
OIS.
Now with these top 5 problems listed, I want
to say that I’m still very excited for this
new iPad.
The new design, face id, that 8 core CPU and
7 core graphics, and
the much more powerful applications that are
being released is making Apple goal of iPads
replacing PC’s much more possible for a
lot of people.
We will be having a lot
more coverage of the iPad Pro as soon as
it arrives, so
make sure you’re subscribed and you enable
those notifications.
This has been Max
with Max tech, and I’ll see
you in the next video!